[Music]
the following
is a presentation of the st louis chess
club
hello everyone and we're back i'm your
host
grand master dennis borosch and we have
another special guest
in fact she is one of the biggest chess
streamers out there she is poland's
favorite a world youth champion
and the first person to be signed to an
esport team
i'd like to introduce you aka namsco
nemo thank you for joining us hello no
thank you very much for inviting me
thank you
it's a pleasure also i like to start
from the start
how did you start your chess career or
what
kind of started your career well
i mean i've been playing chess for a
really long time been playing since i
was pretty much three years
old um so it's been an
absolutely long journey it's i've been
playing chess
competitively since i was three so
i pro pretty much like took a break when
i was 17
and i'm not like fully back into
competitive play but i've been playing
chess for pretty much 18 years of my
life
but what captured you what really got
you
playing chess i think it's the
competitive aspect i think i was just
always very competitive even as like a
kid and i just always wanted to win
tournaments so
it was it was always that as i got older
and one of the highlights of your
protest career was to win the world
youth championship how did that happen
was it tough or was it just an easy
breezy
uh road for you to win um
i honestly think one of the things that
really pushed me to win the
world championship that year
specifically not that like
i don't have a million reasons i want to
win right i think
that year um i just
was bullied in like middle school and
this is like a story i haven't really
told people but
um now that like my mental is a lot more
fresh about it i kind of want to share
the story it's basically i i
kind of got bullied in middle school and
i was like okay
um sort of like chess wasn't really cool
back then
and like you know kids would make fun of
you for being like that chess player
i mean i also had lots of support but i
think it's those negative comments that
really drove me to
prove uh the haters wrong kind of thing
that like yo
i can't be really really good at chess
and i can also be good at everything
else too so
that's what really pushed me sort of
like sort of like
what kills you makes you stronger
exactly what is the guilty makes you
stronger yeah exactly
yeah for sure and i checked that
tournament
and interestingly enough i saw
second place was poland
yes yes it indeed was olivia kyobasa
yeah was it tight towards the end or
was it easier it was definitely tied
towards the end i think i had the same
amount of points as her but my tie break
was a lot
better so um actually no my tie break
was not a lot better
i was just yeah by a slight margin
i i won but yeah it was uh it was a very
very close tournament for sure
so i want to segue into becoming from
a pro chess player to a pro streamer
now i saw the early beginnings of your
streaming career
and you had some struggles with getting
used to
the mechanics can you tell a bit more
about that yeah i mean when i first
started streaming i didn't really know
what a pre-move was well okay this
wasn't even before i started streaming
this was one of my
uh previous matches with alexander botez
i i had never
really played online before and i guess
i had to really
played bullet before either so there was
no point to me learning
like no point to be really pre-moving
but
uh i mean definitely getting used to
playing online chess
while reading chat and also developing
like
you know how to become a streamer really
because i was just kind of thrown into
it
all of those things were definitely
things i struggled a bit to overcome
when i was first starting out but
currently i saw
how you kind of amaze your peers with
your speed
i saw even a tweet of yours showing how
fast you can play bullet by now
so i could see you actually working on
this improvement
improvement for sure um so
talking about that if you could choose
over the board tournament online
tournament which one would you choose to
play in
oh i mean right now i obviously haven't
played uh in person tournaments for a
really long time so
i think i do miss those but i think in
the future i really want to see
maybe a little bit combined some over
the board some online because
it's definitely not realistic for me to
travel everywhere right to play over the
board while streaming while doing all
the other stuff in my life
so i definitely think that could apply
to a lot of other people as well i mean
everybody has work or school or
family or like things that they can't
just
and then go somewhere for two weeks for
right like um so i think online
tournaments could be really beneficial
to
introducing chester lar much grander
skill because
realistically we're not held back by the
like being forced to play over the board
we can play online
it's just that isn't really in place yet
because
chess is still so new to kind of the
esports scene
actually what's very interesting and
actually might be a good news for you
they're introducing a hybrid format i
don't know they i haven't
heard of that yes no i haven't yet oh my
god i'm so excited i haven't heard
anything about like yeah so the hybrid
format is basically you are playing in
one place
so let's say you're playing in
your own apartment and your friend is
playing
on the other side of your apartment so
you're playing online
but in the same place and now it is
officially introduced in
fide tournaments that's really cool
actually so
it's like a formal thing but still you
know playing online
that's really cool that's actually kind
of like how i mean esports
or league of legends and stuff work
before the pandemic like you would be
i mean obviously there's no over the
board but like you still go to the same
place and you play
even though you know you could
technically just be in your apartment
but it definitely gives an element of
like
competition and professionalism yeah
seriously a little bit like in the
protest league
like in the protest league they tried to
go for the esports play
right playing in one stadium one big
stadium
everyone together and had the first
hybrid
match actually in some shape or form
because the players were
staying in front of each other playing
each other
with the computers so not really
interacting physically
not moving any pieces that's really cool
that said you were the first one to
sign for an esport how did that came
about
well i mean i was very very excited to
sign to clg
and um it was really like kind of like a
test for myself to see hey where is
streaming going to take me right because
at that point i think i only had my
channel for a month
and clg reached out and i was like oh my
god this is so exciting because i've
been following the esports team for such
a long time
i mean i didn't sign on as a competitive
chess player or protest player or
you know anything like that i actually
sign on as a variety
content creator so i would say that's a
little bit different for me
because um i mean i don't know how the
competitive or protesting will look like
with all the orgs involved but
for myself it just i think it gave me
like a sense of credibility that
um wow i i'm a content creator you know
and that's
enough excitement in itself so i have a
couple of questions
from chat they're asking what is your
favorite chess book and who is your
favorite player
uh my favorite player is definitely holy
thon um
i mean pretty self-explanatory there i
think you know one of the best female
players ever
just accomplished everything her life
went to like oxford
is now like a professor in china like
she she is just everything
um i mean in terms of gameplay i can't
say i've actually looked closely at her
games but she's just a very inspiring
person
i can tell you your style is not far
from hers
okay well i am glad to hear that i
honestly i haven't seen
well she hasn't actually played a lot in
recent years so i think it could be
forgiven that i wouldn't really be
familiar with the games but
definitely i remember meeting her when i
was younger and just
like instantly you know my coaches would
be like yo hoifan is like the girl
you know you want to be like so i
definitely can say she's had a lot of
impact on my my like
just kind of motivation i think and in
terms of chess book i haven't really
read many chess books
like by myself um i think maybe
it's better if i just say like some of
the books that have had
and like sort of an influence on me uh
one of my favorite authors is jeremy
sillman he
wrote a lot of good intro books to chess
like um how to
reassess your it was called imbalances
or something back when i read it but i
know it got
it went through some editions i guess
how to reassess your chest
yeah i think it was how to reassess your
chest okay i remember i think when i
read it when i was
like six it was it had a different title
i'm pretty sure
um but yeah the other book of his is um
mastering end games or something like
that and that was another book that
had a lot of influence on me when i was
younger i mean i haven't really read
books in
the last 10 years so all this stuff is
from like what back when i was like six
or something but
yeah those were those are the two books
i will always remember
so yes so we've got a couple
of other comments they saw your first
stream it was
great also
have you changed your style and opening
um and when did you find your style
that was the question and i haven't
changed my style
of opening since i was probably like
six i've been playing the same opening
since i was
so young i played the i first played
it's the scotch i remember this very
clearly
and then from the scotch i went to the
spanish and i've been playing the
spanish for the last
like 10 years since i mean obviously i
i've learned how to play d4 openings
i've learned how to play knight f3 i've
learned how to play c4 like i've learned
everything
um but i just never saw a reason
to switch out of the spanish because it
was working so well for me right like
you can play as both black and white
there's like 20 million lines in the
spanish too so if you
don't feel like playing this slide in
the spanish today you can play like one
of the 10 other lines of spanish and it
becomes a whole different opening
so whenever i say i like play only the
spanish i think people think it's very
boring but
i i also don't think people realize
there's like 50 million things you can
do in spanish
whereas if you played something like the
london you're actually stuck
playing the london but in the spanish
you get so much variety so
i think um that's just kind of been my
thing
but in terms of like recently i suppose
i've been trying to switch up my
openings
um part of it is mostly because like
once you play 3000 games i guess in the
same opening you kind of get bored and
you're like okay well
time to test out new stuff like like
yesterday i played a match and i played
primarily d4 which
i hardly ever do um but yeah i mean
like i said it's not like i can't play
openings it's just i have a very clear
preference and i know what i want i know
what kind of style positions i want
um so if d4 can give me that similar
style position i'm happy with it it's
just
usually you know you kind of don't know
what people are going to play
in online blitz whereas in over the
board you can actually prepare against
them
so i'm obviously just more confident
playing
openings i've already seen before yeah
when i play blitz i never thought i'm
gonna say this
but the only thing that
from the beginning connects me u
and xqc is that we all started playing
the scotch
[Laughter]
i mean i did regret it and i did fall
for some tricks
i'm not going to mention who else fought
from for some tricks
but it did happen yeah um
i mean the scotch is definitely one of
the openings that you kind of have no
theory for i think so
definitely a lot of tricks there and by
tricks i mean sometimes you just get
scholars mated too but you know that's
fine
it's okay so
as you mentioned before the polish
opening
i'd like to ask you a little bit about
your polish
fan club or your quarter
polish heritage how that came about
this has been the most absolutely insane
thing to happen to me in streaming
if somebody told me a year ago that hey
look in a year you're going to be a
twitch streamer and
your viewers will be primarily from
poland i would be like
what but now that we're here it's been i
think two weeks since the first ever
um parade from excellent testio so like
bertash
um and it's just been like crazy i think
this has to be the record for most
influential raid
ever i honestly think so it's just been
insane because i mean it's like the
differences i think in
the community not really differences in
community because i think everyone's
like really supportive and like very
positive and that's always the community
i've always wanted for my chat
but just in terms of like
i would just say polish people are built
different like they just built different
i don't know how else to put it
it's been absolutely so much fun having
everybody around now if you're not
familiar with
nemo she has her own vocabulary
she uses build different chad
and many other words so unless
you don't check her stream out you'll
never know what those words mean
yeah for sure i definitely um
i i think i'm i think having me online
for this long just
definitely started using my own english
words
yeah and it's kind of interesting to see
how you sort of ease them from a pro
chess player
to a pro streamer and i
should not forget of asking this
question
did you feel welcomed in the streamer
community
i definitely felt very very welcomed i
mean i think alexandra
really made sure that um you know
everybody
welcomed me both on her channel and
after and you know now
like everything that the community the
chess community has done for me has been
absolutely just amazing like i couldn't
imagine this much support
and also for league and like bellerin
and like all the other games i play and
poker
um everybody has just been so welcoming
and it's just like
really heartwarming i think because um
you can go from being strangers with
somebody to being really close friends
with them and that's super super cool
it's powerful internet i guess and i'm
just noticing that
you actually did a bit of shift from
just chess
to a bit of variety just like in your
chess game you're trying to
widen the appeal and just get some other
games in there
um what can you say about the other
communities how do they
think about chess are they interested in
getting part of
the chess community or chess itself i
can definitely say the league and poker
communities
absolutely love chess it's it's just
crazy like
a lot of the players poker players i've
talked to
all want to play chess or they've all
played chess i mean that one probably
makes a lot more a lot of sense because
people put a lot of
i mean a lot of chess players go pro and
poker and stuff like that
um but it's been really really cool to
just talk to your phone and be like yeah
i absolutely love playing chess you know
and obviously a lot of the people i play
league with also absolutely love play
chess so
it's been absolutely fun and
the other question i wanted to ask uh
you
played pro chess are you hoping to do
some more professional chess
get titles and such i'm definitely
thinking about it i mean
um i'll see how the format for
tournaments comes up i mean i'm
pretty sure like getting norms and stuff
won't change that much but
i'm happy with where i am right now and
you know if opportunities arise i will
definitely not say no
but i also don't want to like give
myself
um an expectation or really like
anything like that so at this point i
don't really want to say like yes i will
try to come back into competitive flight
because i don't know maybe i will maybe
i won't but i think it's maybe
the mystery of whether or not i will do
it that future will tell
yeah it's like you know i for the first
time in my life i don't feel like i need
to plan
the next 10 years of my life out it's
okay if i just decide what i'm to do
today
and i'm just comfortable with that
the other thing that i wanted to ask
there is
if you would have an opening you could
decide decide
what it's about and who
would play who would you invite for your
own tournament
just to play against your face
well i mean i think for this question i
will
probably pick people you know that i've
always dreamed of playing against
um but i i mean
if i was gonna design my own opening it
would probably be something very similar
to the spanish i would just take out
like the
nuances of some of the spanish line that
i don't really like
um like the berlin for example not a fan
of the berlin
but but i think i think i would really
invite some of the more
um what's it called like more active
and attacking and aggressive players
like nepo is really really cool
don't just game the more chad players
yeah the more
chat players exactly like nepo's play
style is so cool
ifon's playstyle is obviously really
cool it's like
um you know all the exciting games that
could happen
coming out of the opening would be
really cool where we don't have to sweat
50 moves for theory you know i think
that's what i really want i
i think i just mostly really want um
kind of a no law no openings kind of
tournament
yeah sort of a theme tournament as well
i guess yeah that's how you
yeah a theme tournament where you're not
allowed to play an opening yeah i would
love that
or yeah kind of like a no opening yeah
no opening tournament
so i've got a couple of questions by the
name of
saint louis chess club and
st louis chess clubs asked i believe
nemo played the 2018 enorm congress
i did i got absolutely destroyed
is a very very i think it's an
understatement of the year
but it was a lot of fun i mean i would
always
do it again because playing norm
tournaments
is something else um but yeah i i got
destroyed i think it's a very simple way
of putting it i
did not perform very well but hey look
it was it was fun it was enjoyable i
mean you did have a fun time right
yeah exactly and that's sometimes all
that matters i mean chess is part
the game plus the community around
exactly
so another question here um has neymar
played outside the u.s
if so what is the country to play chess
in
or tournaments in um so i
i represent canada um but i think i
played most of my tournaments
at least most of the major tournaments
in europe um
you moved around a lot right yeah i
moved around a lot i
i grew up in finland france i grew up in
france finland
so i played a lot in europe i mean
obviously because
i i was living there before i was like
11 then when i came to canada obviously
i started playing a lot more local
tournaments
i honestly think i've only played five
tournaments or so in the us i've not
played in the us at all
um i definitely much prefer playing
um i think european opens
compared to north american opens because
the structure of the
just like the atmosphere of the
tournament is quite a bit different and
that's just kind of where i grew up i
got used to
and actually i guess you already have
the fighting spirit of an american
tournament
you're just as competitive and you want
to win at all costs
so for you playing in europe is actually
a gold mine
definitely i mean europe european
tournaments are very difficult to play i
think
because um people are just very very
strong there i mean
it's not like they're not strong in
north america it's a difficult blade of
both but
um the the tournament format is just
quite different
and there's definitely advantages and
disadvantages to playing in both and
it's all comes down to preference
i think for which one you'd rather play
it
and a little bit of a talk with the tata
steel event right now
that i want to ask you so at the moment
there are not a single female player
invited
for the event so if you had a choice
a who would you pick as a wild card b
what would you change like how would you
change the systems that we have
more competitive female players such as
yourself
um i definitely think that getting
iphone into the tournament
gives the best possibility for like
female representation at chess
tournament because she's obviously the
strongest
um but also in terms of like just female
tournaments and stuff this is something
that i've been thinking about recently
it's just like
um you know chess is one of the
like people always ask why is chess
like gendered right because you know
shouldn't people think the same but i
mean
it's not really about thinking the same
it's more about just the fact that
um being a girl while
doing pretty much anything just kind of
sucks sometimes because you know you get
misogynist comments you get people
telling you that girls can't play chess
you get
like literally it's just so dumb and i'm
just like i definitely hope that at some
point society
is going to i mean we're already moving
on upwards trend so i'm really happy
about that but at some point you know
we'll get to a point where
uh all female players feel comfortable
100 of the time when they're playing
any game and it's not necessarily just
chess i think that's really important in
order to foster a culture
where women can support each other and
um
you know and guys can support women too
and women can support guys like
like literally just if people supporting
each other it's such a foreign concept
sometimes actually
so you don't know why um yeah let me
just
jump in for a second even in your own
career
you were ahead of all the boys in your
category
winning the finnish championships back
to back almost
yeah for sure i mean um when i was
winning when i was winning the finnish
national championships
i was the only girl playing and i was
you know winning them
and you know even that this is one of
the things where people are saying but
guys are always better than girls at the
other day and that's not true i'm still
with compared to the people i was
playing with at the same time
i am still the same or higher than most
of them
and it's not right to compare
the success of one woman to the success
of ten men
i just don't think that's fair people
aren't doing comparison correctly that's
not how statistics works
that's not how the world works and i
think this is a message that a lot of
people need to
hear because um they think that just
because you know
there's magnus carlsen and there's
hoifan and hoifan is not near magnus
cross and therefore all men are better
that's not true
just compare iphone to people who she's
interacted with
in her career right um she's top 100
overall
exactly exactly i mean she is better
than so many
so it's just i really think it becomes a
matter of time and just
needing to get more and more women into
the game and
you know it i mean this might not happen
with
chess in the next hundred years but as
long as we're moving on an upwards trend
as long as society is doing this for
future women in future games i think
that's really important
so i mentioned this to alexandra beautes
in our first interview that
hey what about doing mixed youth events
makes youth events
online where girls and boys constantly
compete with each other because what i
noticed and this is
one of my theory is that when everyone
starts playing
chess they're all around the same rating
but then
there's a separation between the groups
the girls and boys
play on different groups and for some
reason one or another the boys have
higher ratings
but that with time multiplies so if like
the 2300
plays against 2300 they'll be growing
exponentially compared to a field where
2200 is the highest yeah for sure
so if you would combine the fields
especially the youth fields then you'd
see
them growing together i think so too
i definitely think that um we're
getting to a stage where it's probably
possible to compare
to to combine the fields because there's
enough female players now
and kind of see like where that takes
people in chess i mean it's going to
become like
i guess half a society experiment and
the other half you know just to
complete over change of this of the
event i mean
i i don't really want to talk about this
like in terms of
like i have no authority on this subject
whatsoever i'm no longer
um like a super competitive youth chess
player i mean i'm not even
well as a world world youth champion i
think you have the right to have an
opinion
yeah i mean i would say if i was in 2014
if i was complying with the men's
section i would definitely the boys
section i would definitely not be
winning
not under 14. like as simple as that i
would not i
don't think i would have the capability
i mean i'm trying to remember who was
under 14 men
guys champion that year i'm pretty sure
it's probably some like 2400
international master which is usually
the case for
you know under 14 year olds but like i i
definitely think it's like um
if you pull everybody together people
play stronger people and it's just about
not losing motivation
and really just keep grinding at it and
knowing that you can get to that level
and realizing that there is no
gender reason why females
can't be like over like over
everything can't be as good as guys
right yeah i think that's something
that's really important
i agree with that and uh yeah thank you
for saying that um
i'm actually kind of want to mention
judy pogar's example and judy pogar's
example
is very important like she was
playing all these youth events together
with the boys
and guess what once she graduate
graduated from these youth events
she started playing in the big field
became top 50 immediately and
she was invited to the biggest arenas
and it has to do with the fact
that hey of course she was talented but
second of all
she kept up with all the biggest talents
yvonne shook many others she already
faced faced all these players
before her career even started so i feel
that this is
maybe one of the steps but i don't know
what you think about that i mean
it's there's so many things you can do
for just to
improve or like really really encourage
women to play and i think there's a lot
of things that
could happen and things that are easier
to
make happen than other things so i'm
pretty excited
to kind of see like what changes the
governing body of chess feed a
and you know even chess.com is going to
do for the game
and at the moment talking about these
youth and not
youth events but these online events
what is your current favorite that you
like playing in
um i definitely like playing in title
tuesdays i think
online swiss events are really really
fun um arena is a little bit more
scuff for me because you know you can
like when i play an arena tournament i'm
not like
super into it because i know i can leave
any time kind of
known on me but if i'm playing title
tuesday i know i'm stuck there for the
11 games
so i think i really like playing online
swiss events
so right now um if i ask you
one minute chess classical chess got to
choose
one minute one minute one minute of
course one minute everyone knows the
answer to that
i mean it changed so rapidly like you
were a classical player
you were asking the question what is a
free move
yes and then now you're saying
when can i pre-move yeah for sure i mean
now now i'm asking the question should i
pre-move
and the answer is usually no but i
pre-move anyways so
we've definitely come a long way and
it's not necessarily in the best way
all right so thank you so much for being
a guest here
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you
for taking your time thank you so much
for having me
dennis and have a great day thank you
bye-bye all right
bye so thank you so much everybody
for joining us for this interview
and i hope you had a lot of fun you
learned a bit about nemo
and how she changed from pro player to
pro streamer thank you for watching bye
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
you